hi guys
welcome back to another video by simply
learn
in today's video we're going to learn
all about
angular services now if you haven't
watched our videos on angular forms or
components then i highly recommend you
watch them first
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update from us
so now without further ado let's begin
i'm sure you all know that an angular
app is divided
into several components for example you
have
the logo component you have the sign in
component
an image component and say a create
account component
now these components are standalone and
each of them
represents a part of the user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed
common tasks for example accessing the
database
or rendering images on the view tasks
like those
now instead of having to write the code
for
every component you can just make use of
angular services now the service can be
written
once and they're injected into all of
these components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable
or a feature that an application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once
and avoid rewriting of it now the same
code can be injected into several
components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure
a good user experience now that is the
extent of
it components make sure that whatever is
being rendered onto the screen
is right and pristine but
in order to execute tasks we make use of
services
and this approach is ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks
like fetching data from the server
validating user
input or logging directly to the console
to a particular service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app so now
let's talk about a few features of
angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply
a typescript class with an at injectable
decorator
this decorator tells angular that the
class is a service
and can be injected into components that
need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code
they can also inject other services as
dependencies
now these services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the backend
now for example if you want to make ajax
calls you can have
methods to those calls in the service
and then use it as a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data
among several components in angular
services are singleton meaning that only
a single
instance of a service gets created and
the same instance
is used by each and every building block
in the application
and finally a service can be registered
as a part of a module
or it can be registered as a part of the
component
now to register it as a part of the
component you'll have to specify it
in the providers array of the module
i'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better
if we look at a simple demo so in the
next section
we're going to look at a demo but before
that let me tell you the use case so
basically in the demo
what we'll do is we'll create an
employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like
name employee id and their email id
we'll create a database of say three
employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button
it displays the information about that
particular employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employee's details
so without delay let's head to our vs
code
and start learning angular services
hands-on
so here first i've created a folder
called demo underscore angular
within which i've created a file called
hello world
so this was previously used for a
tutorial so
the name is just hello world so don't
get confused
however when you look at the browser
i've written
an initial code here which is angular
services and i have the simply learn
logo
so back in my browser this is what
the ui looks like so uh
to so to understand the concept of
angular services first let's go ahead
and create a component
so here i'm going to say ng
g c
e info i'm creating a component
for employee information
so as you can see inside my
app file we have the e info
component which has these four files so
if you're wondering
what exactly components are and how this
is working
then i highly suggest you watch our
components video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so i'm just typing in the command ng
g service here g stands for generate
and we're generating the service and the
name of the service that i'm providing
is data so now it creates
a service which is going to be
a dot ts file so you can observe that
dot service is appended this indicates
that it is a service
all right as mentioned earlier we have
to display the employee details
correct so for that in my component.ts
file
i'm going to create an array that
displays the employee information
in our case i'm creating uh three
different employee records
so for that i'll have three different
arrays so let me just
call the arrays info
received one indicating this is the
information
of first employee and this is going to
be of type
string and i'll just initialize it to
null
for now all right and i'm
going to create two other
arrays and let me just
change the name of that is all right
so now to retrieve the information i'll
have to create
a method again i'm creating three
methods for
the three different employee records so
i'm going to call the array
get info
[Music]
from service one indicating it's
again for employee one and
i'm just going to leave it as it is for
now i'll tell you how the information is
being received
and i'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records
so let me just copy paste
and here i'm just gonna change
the name of the methods all right
so this is the initial code for
retrieving information
however we have to create the employee
record in
our service so back here in my data.ts
file
what i'm going to do is i'll create
three different records for the
employees
so let me say info1
which is going to be of type string
all right and let me just give
a random names say for example i say
john
matthew
[Music]
all right and employee id
say e 354
and let me just give a random
email id and say jm at abc.net
all right so i'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh
records so let me just create
another one and call it info two
and the name i'm providing is say
rob listen with
a different employee id say 673
and i'm just going to make it rw at
abc.net and another record
for employee number three
and i'm just gonna say rose
adams
[Music]
with some employee id
and an email id all right
so now we've created the employee
records
so what i have to do is i have to create
a method
that returns these employee records
correct
so for that i'm just going to create
another
method called get info 1
which is of type string
and it just returns this
dot info one all right
similarly for the rest of the two
records i'm just gonna retrieve them
[Music]
let's say in four two and get in for
two and again
i'm just gonna make it get in four three
and this is going to return in 4
3 all right so i'm sure you've got an
idea as to what i'm doing here
so basically this information is going
to be retrieved
in our employee component correct
so for that i'll have to make use of
dependency injection
so here i'll have to import the service
that i've created so let's go ahead and
say import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right from
slash data dot service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to
tell angular that when the component is
created
the service instance is also created and
this
instance is being used to perform
particular tasks
and for that we'll also have to include
this in our providers area
so here let me just say providers
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created
we make use of a property so
this property basically allows us to
access
all the methods that are defined in the
service class
all right so here in my constructor
method
i'm just gonna say private
and you can give any name for your
property and here i'm just
giving the name d service
all right and which is of type
data service
all right so now with the help of this
property i can
retrieve information from the service
class so here i'm just going to say
this dot info receipt
equals this dot d service
dot get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it
calls the get info one method in our
service
which returns the information of the
first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is
info received one so similarly for the
next
two methods i'm just going to use the
same piece of code
let me just change it here
and same for the third one
all right so now that we have the logic
behind
what is being displayed let's go ahead
and create
the ui for it here in my html file
i'm going to create an unordered list
[Music]
and now i'm going to make use of
the ng
for director to uh basically
loop over the record and display
everything so
for that i have to make use of a
particular variable so i'll just
say let info
of info received so
um you can check here in our ts file the
array is info received correct so i'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first in
employee record i'm just going to
say info received one
all right and let me just create a class
a bootstrap class of list
group item of list group
info and we're just gonna have to
interpolate
info all right that is basically going
to display
what the information holds what the info
variable holds
all right and here as well let me create
a bootstrap class
called list
group all right i hope this was
clear to you so basically here the
information is being retrieved with the
help of
this method right that is get info from
service one
so in order to call this method we'll
have to bind it
with a button all right so that's what
we're going to do
let's just copy this
and here i'm going to create a button
all right and the type
is button
with name button again
all right so i'm going to bind it with
the click event
so what happens is that when i click on
it this particular
method gets called all right i'm just
pasting the method here and finally
let's just
provide the name employee 1
for the button all right
so uh similarly we'll have to do the
same for
the other two records as well
let me just make this look better all
right
so uh what i'm gonna do is i'm just
gonna paste the same
twice
and here i'm gonna just change the names
i'll say
2 here and this is again for employee 2.
and i'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employee
i'm sorry it's going to be in 4 received
2 this is going to be in 4 received
3 and finally employee 3
all right and lastly we'll have to
include the selector that is
app hyphen e info in our
main component or html
so here let me just
create a custom tag all right and save
this
so now let's go back to our browser and
see what it looks like
so here you can see that three different
buttons have been created
for employee one two and three and when
you click on it
it retrieves the information that is the
name
the employee id and their email ids so
we've successfully
created an angular service and injected
it
into our component to retrieve
information
all right so now the last part of the
use case that we discussed
was uh to add another detail
that is the employee detail in the
record all right
so for that we'll have to take input
from the user
and in our case we're taking the
location now uh we're also
adding the same location for all three
employees
so this is what services do you know
they
can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can
tweak the code a little bit and you can
change the entire
uh view of your application you can add
information you can delete
you can retrieve you can alter etc
all right so for that what we're going
to do is back
in the html file we'll create a form
that basically takes the input so
i'm just going to say
[Music]
form all right
within which i'm going to be defining a
div class
[Music]
within which i'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside of which i'll have the input tag
of type
text and
the name i'm going to be providing it
will be location
all right
and we'll have a value and i'll just
leave it blank and finally i'll have ng
model
so if you're confused as to what i'm
doing here then i suggest you watch
the angular forms uh video
it basically teaches you uh how to work
around with
angular forms all right and now
after this we're gonna have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
[Music]
and i'm gonna just say add info
okay
all right so now when i'm creating the
form
i'll also have to create a template
variable
to access all the values within my form
so if i have to access the location then
i need a variable to access it so here
let me just go ahead
and create a template variable let me
call it
frm and i'm going to make use of the ng
form directive so this tells angular
that uh this variable can be used
to access all the values within the form
and since i'm using form here i'll have
to import it
in my module file
so here i just go ahead
and say import forms module
from angular forms and here in my
imports
[Music]
i'll just say forms module
okay so i've imported the forms module
so now back in my html file what i'm
going to do
is that i'll have to make use of this
template variable
to update my information correct so
i'll have to create another method
that will update information into the
records
so here in my component.ts file
i'll have to create another method
and i'm going to call this method update
info method all right
and uh this basically takes in the
template variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do is
that
it updates the record correct
so i'm going to say this dot
d service dot
add info now you must be wondering what
add info
is i'll just let you know in a minute
and and the value that i'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've
provided as an input which is nothing
but form
dot value dot location
all right so now what happens is that
i'll have to again specify
what add info is and this method is
going to be defined
in the service file correct
so here i'm going to create another
method that's add info
and i'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays so since i'm going to be
pushing the same
information into all of these arrays
that is info one in photo and info three
i'm just going to say this dot info one
dot push off info
[Music]
all right and uh the same for
the other two areas as well
let me just
change these all right so what exactly
i'm doing
is that i have i have a method called
add info
which gets information from the
component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array
and also i have to return it so i'll say
return
this dot info
[Music]
1 all right and i'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info
which basically calls uh the add info
method in our service and passes the
value to it
and in my html file also note that the
button type here is submit
and not button so what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be
uh passed on to the method that is
update info
so here i'll say ng submit
and i'm going to call the method update
info and i'm going to pass
frm as the argument
and now let's save this and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button
saying add info so now i can just go
ahead and
see type usa and when i say add
info and when i check on my
employee one details usa has been added
to the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so i hope this simple demo on angular
services helped you understand the
concept better
i highly recommend you play around and
explore other possibilities so with that
we conclude the session
i hope it helped you thank you so much
for being here
and watch out for more videos from us
until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here